different ratoncito coming from legend
marketing for Latin America we're here
with the forum and young global leaders
have also include evaluation of the
Global Agenda Council on work raining
cognitive sciences and once that the
challenges in Latin America that also
probably is the question of intensity in
what has been really interesting for me
here is to meet with the people from the
private and the public sector concerned
with helping were the initials to
discuss the original particularities and
features getting their products are the
people when it comes to nutrition eating
and physical activity what is really
interesting is to try to see what the
work we're doing in the twice in
government and corporation to which
inspired from one continent to another
the show we need to understand the
special features and their behaviors
that's fine what people are doing were
strict the culture and had it's in
country so that we can tailor our
strategy to better work all together
governments private sector and improve
health and well-being